AND GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
BIG LEGISLATIVE VICTORY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS.
MOMENTS AGO, THE PRESIDENT AND
LAWMAKERS GATHERED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TO CELEBRATE THE
PASSAGE OF THE TAX REFORM BILL.
THIS MARKS THE BIGGEST OVERHAUL
THE TAX CODE IN THREE DECADES.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT'S
REACTION.
>> THESE ARE THE PEOPLE RIGHT
BEHIND ME.
THEY WORKED SO LONG, SO HARD.
IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
HASN'T BEEN DONE IN 34 YEARS BUT
ACTUALLY REALLY HASN'T BEEN DONE
BECAUSE WE BROKE EVERY RECORD.
I GUESS IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
WHEN YOU THINK YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
THIS EXPRESSION.
BUT WE ARE MAKING AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THAT, HAVE
YOU?
PAUL RYAN ADMISSION, WE WERE A
TEAM.
WE WOULD GET TOGETHER AND WORK
VERY HARD, DIDN'T WE?
SEEMS LIKE IT WAS A LOT OF FUN.
IT'S ALWAYS A LOT OF FUN WHEN
YOU WIN.
>> Dana: INDEED.
CHAIRMAN OF THE KEY COMMITTEES
HAD HIGH PRAISE FOR PRESIDENT.
GREATEST PRESIDENCY WE'VE SEEN
NOT ONLY IN GENERATIONS BUT
MAYBE EVER.
>> Dana: THE BILL HEADS TO THE
PRESIDENT FOR HIS SIGNATURE.
LET'S START WITH THE CONGRESSMAN
BECAUSE YOU ARE HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DID YOU THINK THIS WOULD HAPPEN?
>> Jason: NO, NOT ONLY DID
THEY DO THAT BUT THEY REPEALED
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO DRILL IN
AND WIRE.
THERE ISN'T EVEN A TREE TO HUG
WHEN AND WHERE.
ORRIN HATCH GAVE THE MOST
HEARTFELT SENTIMENT.
YOU HAVE PAUL RYAN, A HUGE
COMPLIMENT, SPENDING HIS ENTIRE
CAREER TRYING TO PULL THIS OFF.
A LOT OF PRAISE, PATTING PEOPLE
ON THE BACK.
NEXT YEAR WHEN PEOPLE HAVE MORE
MONEY IN THEIR WALLET, DEMOCRATS
DIDN'T HAVE A PLAN.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A SOLUTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DELIVERING BY
PUTTING MORE PEOPLE'S MONEY IN
THEIR OWN POCKETS.
>> Juan: YOU SAID DEMOCRATS
DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION.
IF REPUBLICANS HAVE A SOLUTION
TO OBAMACARE, BETTER PLAN, THEY
WOULD'VE PASSED IT.
BUT THEY DIDN'T.
HERE COMES THIS PLAN BEING
CELEBRATED TODAY.
HATS OFF TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
REPUBLICANS.
DANA SAYS HIS BIG LEGISLATIVE
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
I THINK IT'S HIS ONLY
LEGISLATIVE COMPLIMENT BUT IT
COMES AT A TERRIFIC COST AND IT
IS YOU GUYS TODAY, YOU ARE
JUMPING.
TOMORROW YOU'VE GOT YOUR VERSION
OF OBAMACARE ROGER NEXT.
>> Jason: HOW DO YOU ARGUE --
>> Juan: REMEMBER WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE 2010 ELECTIONS.
REPUBLICANS USED OBAMACARE
AGAINST THE DEMOCRAT
SUCCESSFULLY.
ANTICIPATE THE SAME THING NOW
WITH THIS BILL.
IT'S BEING CALLED, ACCORDING TO
THE POST, THE WORST LEVEL OF
SUPPORT FOR ANY LEGISLATION IN
THREE DECADES.
>> Kimberly: DON'T FORGET TO
HIT THE POLL.
>> Dana: 'S >> Dana: YOUR
>> Dana: 'S >> Dana: YOUE
>> Dana: 'S >> Dana: YOUT
>> Dana: 'S >> Dana: YOUL
>> Dana: 'S >> Dana: YOUI
>> Dana: 'S >> Dana: YOUG
ABOUT PEOPLE NOT ON EMPLOYEE
INSURANCE, A NARROW SLICE OF THE
POPULATION WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT OBAMACARE.
THIS IS 80% OF AMERICANS WILL BE
THE WAY WE PAY FOR SOMETHING.
>> Greg: IT COULD HAVE BEEN
SIMPLER.
IN OUR PERFECT WORLD WE WANTED
TO BE AS SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE BUT
COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS SYSTEM
IT IS SIMPLER.
IT'S LIKE YOU ARE COMPARING A
COLORING BOOK TO ATLAS SHRUGGED.
MY FAVORITE PART ABOUT THIS, AND
I WILL TOUCH ON THE INDIVIDUAL
TAXES.
DRILLING ANWAR.
OBAMACARE MANDATE.
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY IS WHAT I
SHOP LEFT.
PEOPLE ARE OVERDOSING ON FOOT
TRULY -- PATCHOULI.
>> Kimberly: IT'S A VERY BAD
SMELL.
>> Greg: DESTROYING OBAMACARE.
AND TAXES ALL IN ONE DAY.
IT'S SANTA CLAUS FOR A FREE
MARKET FREE MINDER.
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE, YOU
CAN'T UNDERPLAY WHAT A BIG DEAL
IT IS.
HE REMOVED SOMETHING THAT WAS
COERCIVE, SOMETHING THAT PUNISH
PEOPLE AND FORCE THEM TO BUY
SOMETHING WHEN THEY SHOULDN'T.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING OH, MY GOD.
MILLIONS ARE GOING TO LOSE
INSURANCE.
NO, THEY ARE GOING TO CHOOSE NOT
TO GET INSURANCE.
THAT'S AMERICAN.
THAT'S DIFFERENT.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT IS FOR CHOICE.
>> Juan: THE CHOICES MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS WITHOUT INSURANCE.
>> Greg: BY CHOICE.
>> Juan: I WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
CHOOSE.
WHAT IS IT GOING TO DO TO THE
REST OF THE HEALTH CARE
STRUCTURE?
IS GOING TO CAUSE IT TO IMPLODE.
PEOPLE IN THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
ARE LETTING PEOPLE GO.
INSURERS.
>> Juan: LET'S SEE.
>> Dana: THAT WILL BE A
COMPLAINT POSSIBLY.
>> Kimberly: YOU REMEMBER BACK
IN THE DAY, WHENEVER THAT WAS,
YOU TALKED ABOUT, AND WE
DISCUSSED IT.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN A SMART MOVE.
I WONDER WHAT THE CONFERENCE AND
THINKS OF THIS.
TO PUT THIS FORWARD HEAD OF
OBAMACARE REPEAL AND REPLACE
BECAUSE OF REPEALING THE MANDATE
AND TAX REFORM PUTTING A WIN ON
THE BOARD.
EFFECTIVELY DEFUNDING OBAMACARE
WITH HIS MANDATE.
>> Dana: ONE THOUGHT.
I WANT TO ADD A QUESTION.
I THINK IT WORKED OUT THE WAY IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO.
IF YOU THINK OF THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR, THE PRESIDENT AND SOME OF
HIS AIDES WERE GOING AFTER
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS
IT'S ALMOST AS IF THEY HAD TO
GET THROUGH THE FAILURE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK TOGETHER.
I THINK IT WORKED OUT.
PASSED 400 BILLS IN THE SENATE
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING.
JUAN SAYS THIS IS ONLY A
SINGULAR LEGISLATIVE
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
IF YOU ARE DOING THREE THINGS IN
ONE BILL ALL AT ONCE, THEN IT IS
SEVERAL ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
PLUS YOU ADD THE CIRCUIT COURT
JUDGES.
THE SENATE REALLY DELIVERED.
>> Jason: AND YOU HAVE
NEIL GORSUCH ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
THE PRESIDENT GOT DONE AND NOT
THEY ONLY NEEDED TO GET TO THE
50 VOTE THRESHOLD.
THEY MISSED THAT OPPORTUNITY.
NEVERTHELESS, COMING ON
CHRISTMAS, A HUGE VICTORY.
NOBODY BUT NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO
JUSTIFY AND "PAY FOR" ALLOWING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KEEP
THEIR OWN MONEY IN THEIR OWN
WALLET.
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM WITH THE
DEMOCRATS AS THEY SOLD OBAMACARE
ON A LIE.
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR.
SAVE $2500.
PEOPLE YOU GET TO KEEP MORE OF
YOUR MONEY, THAT'S WHAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Juan: SO MANY INVITATIONS
NOW THAT REPUBLICANS, EVEN ON
THIS DAY OF CELEBRATION, SETTING
THEMSELVES UP FOR I GUESS WHAT
SOME PEOPLE CALL A TITLE WAVE
ELECTION.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE 2018, A
TSUNAMI.
WHAT WE SEE IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" POLL
IS THE DEMOCRATS HAVE AN
11-POINT REFERENCE IN TERMS OF
WHO CONTROLS CONGRESS.
THE MOST STUNNING NUMBER,
DEMOCRATS ARE SEEN BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS BETTER ABLE
TO HANDLE THE ECONOMY THAN
REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS HOW DAMAGING THIS BILL
IS.
>> Greg: IT REALLY HAS BEEN A
BAD YEAR FOR TRUMP ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS TAX BILL AND THE
JUDGES IN THE NEW ENERGY POLICY
AND ISIS, DEREGULATION.
IMAGINE WHAT A GOOD YEAR WOULD
GOOD YEAR.
IF THIS IS A BAD YEAR, A GOOD
YEAR, WE MIGHT HAVE HEART
ATTACKS.
THIS IS A CONSEQUENTIAL
PHENOMENON.
FOR THE SANITY OF PEOPLE LIKE
ROSIE O'DONNELL, BEFORE THEY
COMPLETELY IMPLODE AND END UP
BEING INCARCERATED AGAINST THEIR
WILL, YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THIS IS
AN EFFECTIVE CONSEQUENTIAL
PHENOMENON.
IT'S AN EFFECTIVE PRESIDENCY
EVEN IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT.
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT.
OR ELSE YOU'RE GOING TO GO
HAVE COOPERATIVE REPUBLICANS ON
THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
OBAMA'S FIRST YEAR, HE HAD THE
MAJORITIES OF DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE AND SENATE AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO HIS SIGNATURE
ACHIEVEMENT WHICH WAS OBAMACARE
I DON'T THINK TAX REFORM IS
GOING TO BE THAT WAY FOR
REPUBLICANS.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOOD?
WHEN YOU SAY EFFECTIVE, WHAT
DROVE THIS WAS REPUBLICANS
SAYING OH, MY GOSH.
I THINK LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID
THIS.
IF WE DON'T HAVE TAX REFORM
AFTER THE FAILURE OF OBAMACARE
REPEAL, IT WILL BE DEVASTATING
FOR THE PARTY.
WE WILL GO INTO 2018 AND WE WILL
BE SHELLACKED.
THAT'S WHAT DROVE THIS IN SEVEN
WEEKS, EVERYBODY HAD TO GET ON
BOARD, BITE YOUR TONGUE, DON'T
SAY IT'S A BAD BILL.
DON'T SAY ALL THE MONEY IS GOING
TO THE RICH AND BIG
CORPORATIONS.
>> Kimberly: WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS YESTERDAY.
PAUL RYAN HAS BEEN PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT.
HE'S BEEN STUDYING THE NUMBERS
>> Dana: KEVIN BRADY HAD
SEVERAL HEARINGS FOR MONTHS
LEADING UP TO THIS AND NOBODY
WAS PAYING ATTENTION.
A LOT OF THESE PIECES THAT ENDED
UP IN THE BILL, THERE WERE
HEARINGS ON THAT.
AS I RECALL.
>> Greg: DEMOCRATS THINK IT'S
A BIG WIN FOR CORPORATIONS.
DEMOCRATS ONLY REALIZE THAT
COLLEGES, ACTIVIST GROUPS, AND
NFL TEAMS ARE MADE OF PEOPLE.
THEY ARE MADE OF PEOPLE BUT
CORPORATIONS MUST BE THIS
MACHINE.
NOBODY GETS UP IN THE MORNING
AND GOES TO THEIR OFFICE, WHICH
HAPPENS TO BE A CORPORATION
WHICH HAPPENS TO MAKE THINGS.
THE MORE PROFITABLE THEY ARE,
THE BETTER THINGS THEY CAN MAKE
AND GET A CHEAPER AND GIVE
RAISES.
BUT THEY AREN'T PEOPLE.
THEY ARE MONOLITHS.
THEY AREN'T HUMAN.
THERE IS NO TENURE IN A
CORPORATION BUT THERE IS TENURE
IN COLLEGE.
>> Juan: WHEN I AM SAYING IS
AMERICANS LIKE CORPORATIONS.
THE WAY DONALD TRUMP SOLD THIS
BILL WAS IT'S GOING TO CREATE
JOBS, THAT IF YOU GIVE THE
CORPORATIONS MORE MONEY, THEY
ARE GOING TO INVEST MORE.
CORPORATE LEADERS, AND NO
INDICATION FROM HISTORY GIVEN
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE REAGAN
TAX CUTS THAT WHAT HAPPENS TO
PAYCHECKS.
>> Jason: WHO DO YOU THINK THE
SHAREHOLDERS ARE?
THEY ARE THE UNIONS, THE
INDIVIDUALS BUYING INTO THESE.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING TO
SELL NEXT YEAR?
YOUR TAXES WERE FINE.
IN FACT, THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HIGHER.
>> Juan: THEY WILL SIMPLY SAY,
WHY IS IT THE CORPORATIONS GET
80% OF HIS BENEFIT AND YOU GET
NOTHING, BUDDY.
>> Jason: THE RATES ARE ON THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL.
THEY OWN THE 401(K) PLANS.
THE REASON THE STOCK MARKET HAS
BEEN ZOOMING IS BECAUSE THIS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Dana: CAN WE GET KIMBERLY
THE LAST WORD?
>> Kimberly: MOST CERTAINLY.
>> Greg: THAT IS IT.
THAT IS YOUR LAST WORD.
>> Kimberly: IT WAS EXCELLENT.
>> Juan: I THINK THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO DO GREAT IN 2018.
>> Kimberly: THE INDIVIDUAL
ASPECT.
I'M GOING TO ALLOW YOU TO DECIDE
WHAT TO DO WITH YOUR MONEY.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF IT.
MAYBE YOU HAVE MORE EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS.
IF YOU WANT TO TRY TO PUT A DOWN
PAYMENT ON A HOUSE OR SOMETHING,
DO SOMETHING FOR YOUR CHILDREN.
YOU WILL BE GETTING --
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT MY YACHT
AND MY SERVANTS.
BECAUSE I AM EVIL AND RICH.
>> Dana: YOU HAVE SERVANTS?
>> Greg: IT TAKES PEOPLE ALONG
TIME TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY CONSIDER THEMSELVES
WEALTHY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE, IT TAKES 30
YEARS TO GET TO A POINT WHERE
YOU GET TO A POINT YOU BEEN
PAYING ALL YOUR LIFE.
NOW YOU'RE BEING DEMONIZED.
>> Juan: I FIND IT INTERESTING
BECAUSE TODAY I WAS ON A FOX
TELEVISION SHOW.
>> Greg: I HOPE IT WASN'T
"DAILY BRIEFING."
C7 YES, IT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> Dana: I WENT ON AND ON?
I WILL TELL YOU REPUBLICAN
DEALING WITH THE MEDIA.
YOU HAVE TO SAVE YOURSELF.
THEY HAVE A TASK IN FRONT OF